I think yesterday you would have heard
some news about inflation today you may
have seen what the bank of England has
announced with interest rates and I'm
sure that actually fills many of you
with some anxiety right and some concern
about what's going on and what does that
mean for you and your families now I'm
here to tell you that I am totally 100
on it and it is going to be okay and we
are going to get through this and that
is the most important thing I wanted to
let you know today now you should know
like I know this won't make it any
easier but what we're grappling with
here is something that many countries
around the world are all program
grappling with at the same time as we
are right now so if you look at interest
rates in Australia or in Canada in New
Zealand
um across the world they're all at high
levels actually interest rates in Europe
the highest they've been in for 20 years
because they're all grappling with
inflation in the same way that we are
many of you may have friends or family
in those places and if you spoke to them
they'd tell you the same thing now that
doesn't make it any easier of course I
know that but it's important for you to
know that we're not alone in dealing
with this and I know how this is and
that's why at the beginning of the year
I made a speech and I set out my five
priorities for the country that I wanted
to deliver as your prime minister the
first of those was to halve inflation
I know how important this is that's why
I said it as my top priority and look
it's not easy right routing out
inflation is not easy it requires
difficult decisions doesn't happen
overnight but if we don't get on top of
it it would just get worse and it would
last longer and that's not going to do
anyone any favors it's not going to be
good for you and your families in the
long run and even though it means I have
to make some difficult decisions that's
the type of prime minister I am because
I want to do the right thing for you and
your families in the long term now look
why does inflation matter right like why
why why did it matter to me why did I
set it as my top priority is it's pretty
simple it's because inflation eats into
the pounds in your pocket it's as simple
as that makes us everybody poorer it
means prices go up it means your savings
get eroded it puts jobs and livelihoods
at risk and that's why it's so important
that we target it and get it down that's
why I said I wanted to halve it on its
way to getting it back down to two
percent where it belongs and I am
absolutely confident
that if we hold our nerve and stick to
our plan we will do that right and you
should feel the same confidence that I
do because we are going to get through
this and we're going to get this done
now why do I feel confident what is that
plan I'm talking about well three parts
to it the first is I've got to make sure
government is doing everything that it
needs to do and that means being
responsible with our borrowing right
because we cannot in a situation a
situation like this borrow too much
money because that much makes everything
worse so that means much as I would love
to I'd love to cut your taxes tomorrow
right you love that I'd love that of
course I would right that's hard to do
because it means I have to borrow more
money to do it right another thing is I
can't say yes to every single thing that
people want me to spend more money on
right because that would mean we'd have
to borrow money to do all of that that
means I have to make some difficult
choices I have to prioritize same as all
of you do in your household budgets I
have to do the same thing too and it
means when we're trying to figure out
how we pay all our fantastic public
sector workers I need to think about
what's afford audible what's responsible
again so I can manage our borrowing now
none of those things that I talked about
are easy right those are all difficult
decisions that I have to make but if I
just gave into the easy thing every time
that would just mean more and more
government borrowing that just puts fuel
on the fire makes inflation worse pushes
up interest rates even higher so even
though it's tough for me in the short
term doesn't make my life easy anyone
who tells you that it would be easy
isn't being straight with you I want to
be straight with you that means I do
have to make these difficult decisions
but that's the right thing to do it's
the right thing to do for you and your
families in the long run and that's why
I'm going to stick to the course and
manage our borrowing now the second part
of the plan is making sure that we
tackle all those areas where inflation
is particularly bad right energy is an
obvious one right the bills that you've
had to pay over the last year have been
extraordinary right absolutely
extraordinary never seen anything like
it now I'm pleased they're going to be
starting to come down right so bills are
going to come down about 430 quid
starting in July that's good news that
hopefully we're over the worst of this
and they'll keep coming down after that
but that's just now we need to make sure
this doesn't happen again and that they
keep coming down that means we need to
have more energy so we're investing more
in renewable energy like offshore wind
building new nuclear power stations but
also making sure that we get more energy
here at home from the North Sea more oil
and gas which we're going to need for
the next few decades as we transition to
a cleaner future so we're investing in
that too now food is another area where
your weekly shop right has gone up far
too much in the in the past few months
especially so we're looking at the
supermarkets making sure that they're
behaving responsibly and fairly when it
comes to pricing all those products to
make sure that we're easing the burdens
on your weekly shop and then when it
comes to jobs I think most of you are
probably reading the paper you'll have
seen that you know businesses everywhere
really need people to work at the moment
and finding it hard to find them almost
everywhere so what we're doing is
reforming our welfare system to make
sure that if you can work then you
should be working shouldn't be able to
just be at home so we're going to reform
our welfare system to make sure we're
doing that but at the same time we're
also cutting the cost of child care to
make it easier for those working parents
who want to work to be able to go back
to work after they have children because
that's something that I think will make
a difference too so that's the that's
the kind of second part of the plan just
going after all those specific things
then the third part of the plan is
helping those who most need help through
the worst of this now how have we done
that well most importantly we've helped
with your energy bills you might not
know this but we actually made a
decision I made a decision when I was
your Chancellor to tax the kind of
excess profits that the energy companies
are making because of the war in Ukraine
then use that money to help pay all your
energy bills and so that support is
worth about half of your typical
family's Energy bill it's worth about 1
500 pounds of support that is what the
government has done over the past
several months now that's the scale of
what we've done it's enormous it's like
the furlough scheme quite frankly in its
size but that and I know it's bad and
you're still looking at these bills
saying oh my gosh these are massive
bills but that's after we've taken about
1500 quid off them that gives you a
sense of how much we've tried to help on
energy but it's not just on energy we've
also providing extra help for people who
really need a bit of extra help so those
on the lowest incomes the national
living wage has gone up hopefully many
of your wages have gone up like the
national living wage over the last year
because want to make sure those on the
lowest income see that benefit
pensioners whether it's your parents
your grandparents their state pension
has gone up several hundred pounds this
year to help them and anyone who's on
Universal Credit they're also getting an
extra 900 pounds this year of support so
you know those who need a little bit of
extra help are really getting that help
from the government and at the same time
the things that you know you guys do a
lot which is travel we're trying to help
there so we've cut fuel Duty which will
save you about 100 quid this year for
those of you that drive also bus fares
with cat bus fares at two pounds outside
of London just to help people as they're
getting around so all those things and
we can talk later about the other things
we're doing hopefully we'll just ease
the burden as we get through the worst
of this inflation challenge